okay so I want to introduce to you a guy
that you guys know very very well mr.
Aaron price we make a very special
introduction for my main man Gary Vee
all right hello there we go
what's up everybody I got the captain's
chair
what up Jersey how many people here know
the Gary Vaynerchuk thank you how many
people here have been provided what he
loves to call and I think it's so
appropriately identified value from his
content thank you if you don't know Gary
before we do that let's clap it up for
this [ __ ] day how nice is this that's
the real star of the show
forget the panel's the [ __ ] Sun came
out and that brings us to our first
question
yes Gary talks about knowing his
audience yes there's a varied group of
of attendees here corporates maybe some
kids yep and we're cursing yeah I always
curse announcing we've talked about this
yes if you could prevent it would you
I mean look I've been on TV 200 times I
haven't cursed I understand it's
inappropriate and I'm not unaware that
like 20 people just now are like oh
that's off-color I don't like that and I
respect that I'm not I have empathy for
how I'm consumed
it's just when I see this many people I
default into that I default into my
jersey stuff I default into what Eddie
Murphy and Richard Pryor did that I was
obsessed with as a kid so that's just
what happens and at some level and I
think a lot of you know this like at
some level in life whether you got lucky
like I did at a very young age or when
you're 90 or somewhere along the line
you start realizing that it's not about
who cares what other people think it's
if you feel good about your intent and
don't think you're trying to do
something wrong you have to let the
chips fall where they fall and so for me
that's what it is it's it's I'm not
upset or disappointed or confused why
somebody doesn't like
the bravado or the cursing I just I just
have made a choice that I don't I'm not
trying to do anything wrong
it's how I communicate and and you just
have to move forward and I'm not
criticizing you I'm thinking about there
are strategic relationships of potential
I know how to make money I'm never
scared of losing money have you ever
lost the deal because of the language
100% yes yes didn't care nope where are
you from written at net score right like
I think you know this is a good thing
for a lot of the entrepreneurs and
business people here way too many people
play in what's only in front of them
without understanding the net net score
so seven years ago I started an agency
that was selling people something they
didn't want it wouldn't have been hard
for me to figure out how to sell PR or
television or SEO but I didn't want to
because I knew where the puck was going
I knew where social was going and so I
was okay with losing deal after deal
after deal in two thousand nine ten
eleven which I did because I knew I was
affecting the people in the room with my
thesis and I knew that I was gonna be
right and now in twenty sixteen
seventeen fifteen a lot of those same
people who laughed me out of the room
who thought I was wrong are coming back
and giving me a lot of money because I
played out to be right so in the net-net
of a decade I won even though maybe I
lost in that year or two or three so you
have the good fortune of being more
right than wrong yes most people are
more wrong than right that's why I'm
sitting up here and that's just true
laughs that's the game like that's the
game like that's right by the way and
you know what I love that if I do my
videos and spew my [ __ ] and for the next
two years I'm just wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong then I don't deserve to sit
up here like and so I love the
meritocracy of that like I'm not sitting
up here because I'm cute or I'm cool I'm
sitting up here because I've been right
enough and I bring people value in that
rightness if they decide I've had 40
people in the last month email me that
they've made tens of thousands of
dollars being a snapchat filter designer
when they had eight bucks in her bank
account that's why they want to drive
from Philly and see me right like like
that's why not because like not
cuz I'm clever because I realize that if
I can bring more value than I take back
in return that I'm valuable and I think
that people are way too short-sighted
and are looking for short-term results
and are not looking to provide that and
are looking at it from what's in it for
me and that's just not how I see it
because I don't think business is a
one-year game if I did by the way let me
save you time if you start seeing my
behavior cashing in and trying to
extract then you know that I've decided
in 24 36 months it's a wrap
right that I don't need it anymore but
like doing the right thing up front
always brings long-term values but tell
people win it I mean you had a book
launch right like yep there was there
was a lot of lead-up yes - I was
battling hard for 3-4 months tell people
about the if they haven't read the book
in in a minute or less
what's the jab and when when is the
appropriate time to bring the right hook
oh you mean - Jab Jab right hook you
know it's a thesis I believe in give
value give value give value and then ask
I think a lot of you out there that do
know my stuff some of you have confused
it as give give give and take I've had a
lot of people ask me why they didn't
convert and when I look at their tactics
it's because they're trying to take
they're not asking so for me if you've
watched every video that was free if I
emailed you back four times if I
responded to you six times on social if
I shook your hand four times here and
then book number five comes out and you
decide not to spend that $18 I'm not
crippled by that because I don't think
any of my actions that I'm doing entitle
me to anything from you I think what
they entitled me to is a solid ask that
feels appropriate but if I convert
that's really up to the quality of what
I'm delivering for you at that moment
and I think that way too many people are
entitled I think way too many people are
entitled I think way too many people
complain it just is what it is the
market doesn't care right like the
market the game doesn't care where you
grew up or your mom didn't do this for
you or you don't have any good
developers around you or it just doesn't
care it's the market and you have to
adjust to that and so I equally do that
when you're at the top or doing well
you're only as good as your last step
bad it doesn't matter that I've been
good
this for 20 years if I suck in 2017 18
and 18 I'm gonna lose so there's a you
know the the whole ethos of propellor
yes is what we say idle ideas don't fly
right and there's a lot of people who I
wonder are sitting in maybe a cubicle
and watching your stuff getting all
fired up but not taking their ideas to
the next level what do you tell those
guys well some of those guys by the way
feel like maybe they can't take the risk
maybe they've got young kids at home
they don't have the the financial
wherewithal I tell them that I respect
them and I understand and I tell them to
do the best job they can to try to feel
what it might feel like in 30 or 40
years if they don't at least try
I think regret is the scariest feeling
and I think I think if you really
analyze 70 80 90 year olds that lost a
lot of money don't have a lot of money
versus ones that are okay but have a lot
of regret of never going for it it's a
pretty interesting conversation even the
cameraman here is giving me a little
love and that shake like it's an
interesting conversation that when I
look at an 80 year old who was middle
class but loaded with regret because he
didn't have the guts to go for it for
somebody who didn't have a lot of money
and had a struggle and things of that
nature like it's just funny the person
with regret feels more in pain and and
and I try to talk about that because you
know I just think it's real and then you
know I had a video recently go quite
crazy on Facebook that I was talking to
22 to 25 year olds I think it's
extremely practical to be high risk in
the first five years out of college even
with debt sitting there because of 2728
you're more than welcome to get that
standard stable job and just chip away
with it but at that first five years you
can go after all your dreams and
ambitions and thoughts and needs and so
it's an interesting theme what people
react to um I I think a lot of it has to
do with regret and I think my intuition
about being an old soul and spending
time with old demo people has given me
some vibe that makes me say [ __ ] it
doesn't matter what you think when
you're 20 30 40 and matters but you're
making decisions on how you think you're
gonna feel at 60 and 70 and if you
actually listened to 60 and 70 and 80
year old people it's just not how it
plays out so why don't you figure that
out and reverse it back what do you
think about the you start
hot [ __ ] right now you got a lot of
young kids and older people raising
capital but what do you think you know
do you think it's over
I think it's celebrated it's definitely
over celebrated welcome to propeller
like like like it's the most over
celebrated thing going on right now like
yo I'm a founder cool like you raised a
lot of money you've never accomplished
anything like like I'm an entrepreneur
is like saying I sing songs right like
but do you make money singing songs are
you Beyonce like just because you're an
entrepreneur doesn't mean anything and
everyone's like yo I'm an entrepreneur
I'm like cool are you a winning
entrepreneur are you a money-making
entrepreneur like will you be an
entrepreneur in four years when the
economic meltdown comes or are you gonna
be working at JPMorgan so I'm uh I think
shit's ugly I think a lot of people I
just met will be out of business because
they don't have a business they have an
idea and they're trying to raise money
money's getting tighter it's about to
get real tight in the next five to ten
years nobody knows it could happen
tomorrow but it's coming there's a lot
of indicators of like China's propelling
up the global economy like like faking
it like it's coming it's coming
and and so if you're in the audience
right now with your startup I'm gonna
give you one really good piece of ice I
truly believe it is start figuring out
how to make money because if you're
sitting right now and you burn and your
life depends on raising your next round
or your first round you are extremely
vulnerable and I highly recommend and I
don't care how bright the sun is shining
and I don't give a [ __ ] how delicious
the red bull [ __ ] tastes you better
get real [ __ ] practical right now
because you're coming gamble if because
let me tell you why because you have to
understand what happens next and this is
happening general issue
this happens every 10 years what happens
next is you go and get a job like like
like like stop being not practical and
then I mean like it's just unbelievable
and there's plenty people with jobs and
I'm not saying I mean I love jobs I've
always had a job like being the founder
of a business that doesn't make money
is losing not winning until you've
turned it into making money you're
losing and all of you think you're
winning why cuz you've said you were a
[ __ ] founder let's talk so listen
let's dig in on that though because I
know one of the things you love to
reference is one of your early calls
that Instagram was a cheap I write yes
and I took a lot of [ __ ] heat they're
alien dollars I was stupid I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about and how
much revenue did they bring in when they
were bought zero exactly so how do you
differentiate like there are guys that
it was [ __ ] 100 million people using
in four minutes you've got a hundred
million users on your [ __ ] did you
get app but it starts with one if you do
good you won I'll come talk to me I'll
give you more money
I love getting Gary fired of us what I
mean what's the difference between
Instagram I said a hundred [ __ ]
million yeah yes my product but they
started they started with woman I like
for [ __ ] yes they started with one
but in [ __ ] four minutes they had
fifty thousand four hundred that like
you've been at it for eighteen months
and nobody gives a [ __ ] it's time to
rethink that [ __ ] that and but that's
the heart of my question for people who
here who have ideas that don't have
built-in revenue models that long do
they go before they say you know what
I'm not instagramming I'm not [ __ ]
Nostradamus I have no idea
here's what I know I know that I know
that the first thing you should do is
stop lying to yourself I wish I was the
quarterback of the New York Jets in six
four guess what I'm not and way too many
people here are hoping and dreaming that
there are not Renaud
if you are in your mid to late 20s or
older and you've never really made money
and I mean slinging blow pops in sixth
grade
I mean burning music on a CD and flip in
it I mean [ __ ] ghetto [ __ ]
entrepreneur [ __ ] and now you're 26 and
you've never really made money you're in
trouble
like you've got to understand who you
are
guess what the forty first person that
worked for Facebook made a fuckload more
money than most anybody else there's way
too many of you sitting on the grassy
knoll right now that would be
unbelievable number fours sevens 18s
thirty twos that could make a lot of
money be happy have great work-life
balance not deal with the insane
pressure and the [ __ ] suicidal
thoughts and the depression
and the [ __ ] I don't wanna everybody
in my family said it wasn't gonna work
now it's not gonna work they're gonna be
right and I'm gonna have to eat that
[ __ ] for the rest of my life all that
[ __ ] if you just deployed some
self-awareness some front and didn't get
romanced by entrepreneurship being the
cool thing and I'm very passionate about
that because right now it's all fine and
haha
Gary's making funny jokes yeah he's
saying it's very cool you have to
understand there's an enormous amount of
pain on the back end of this it's real
it's it's emotional pain its financial
pain and that scares me and I want to
talk about it because it's real and it's
not because I'm right or because I'm
winning and you can't it's because it's
data just look what's happening look
what's happening every trend of what's
getting funded who's winning who's going
out of business looks exactly like the
early 2000s looks exactly like the
mid-2000s like it's here it's here and
just like every other time it's one
event
it's one big startup that none of us
think could go out of business closes
its doors right it's one report that
scares every VC out of their skin and it
and that's it and so it's not like go
get a job you suck it's how practical
are you like are you just dreaming how
many people of the number I mean ice
every time we've met there's a line out
the door people want to pitch you ideas
how many of those percentage-wise are
good do you think are investable or have
legs 1% and that sounds high so what are
those other 99 guys do I mean listen you
have to understand just cuz you're a
human being doesn't mean you're entitled
to be a successful entrepreneur they do
what everybody else does in every genre
you want to be an NFL player and an NBA
player you try you're not good enough
you do something else you want to be in
famous actor you go to LA you wait
tables you try to be on a show it
doesn't happen you do something else I
don't know what they do like something
else but they're not gonna build a
million dollar business how do you mean
million dollar businesses are actually
built to sustain like the data is not in
our favor and I'm not trying to be
cloudy in this Sun I'm trying to save
people some money and some heartache and
create some upside this is just
practicality like it's it's just data
we're not talking about it and listen a
lot of you know my schpeel I'm not
excited to talk about this I'm
happy-go-lucky I'm positive I'm crush it
but I'm [ __ ] telling you the truth
it's just here right now and and what
that means by the way let me explain a
lot of you have businesses that actually
could be successful the problem is you
have 17 employees when you should have
five a lot of you have businesses that
could be successful but you want to have
a nice office right in Soho instead of
being somewhere shitty right like a lot
of you could have businesses that are
successful but you come to [ __ ]
propellor a waste time instead of
building your business well what what no
no no no not that last part that last
part and all the other [ __ ] like are you
building a business like you better
[ __ ] work tomorrow and the only
reason some of you will is is because
it's gonna rain because if it was like
this today tomorrow you'd all be
somewhere and and that's just losing and
that's happening at scale so look right
one of the things that I promise people
here is that we will help save them time
in building their businesses from
listening to guys like you and the
hundred other speakers that we have so
I'd argue that point a bit because I do
think you need to stay connected stay
educated and stay on your a-game
yes what foundation of something but
there's a million want renews all right
yes I mean how many twenty five year
olds don't you with with a cool idea
looking for a check and thinking that
they're gonna go by the fancy Soho
office of course and by the way a good
percentage of them are gonna win I hope
you're sitting there and getting mad at
me and saying [ __ ] this guy and I can't
wait to get your email saying oh you
said I wasn't gonna win a propellor
I built a hundred million dollar
business respect great I want that I
hope every [ __ ] person looking at my
face right now wins everything money
life health great I want that more than
anybody why not be the greatest I just
think there's an enormous lack of
practicality right now all right let's
move in in the positive direction so so
that was the positive direction more in
the positive direction that was follow
up on on that to keep that train going I
think that's positive people
pontificating here like yeah we're all
gonna [ __ ] do it this is true
unfortunately
I think that's I think that's horseshit
yeah that's the whole point here right
expose people to what works and what
doesn't work so that they can fail
faster okay so if somebody here has an
idea yes step one build it
when do they fund it when do they call
you whenever vayner/rse never if they
can pull it off why give up your
business if you can build it build an
app and get a job on the side hustle and
[ __ ] make money and put it back into
your business it's easy to raise money
and what's funny is a lot of you're like
[ __ ] I'm struggling well then you really
suck struggles real when was the last
time you were depressed about
entrepreneurship never never know
because I got it's my calling it's the
only thing I ever wanted it was why I
was depressed and school my whole life
this was the game I was born for this is
all I know I would suffocate if I
couldn't do this I love when bad day sir
yesterday was a [ __ ] day the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] like 21 hours how was
yesterday [ __ ] like so many bad things
happen yesterday yesterday was [ __ ] like
I'm like like terrible but I love this
is a personal business but like it's
great like it's much better than [ __ ]
doing something that I don't want to do
but I mean there must be times when
maybe you don't feel depressed but you
feel the struggle right you feel like
yesterday the struggle had what every
second right and wake up today right
what keeps you going what keeps you
jumping out of bed I have no other
option this is my oxygen I wasn't into
other [ __ ] like you were this is all I
ever knew I'd [ __ ] pick flowers and
sell it at for lemonade my hobby in the
summer was washing people's cars how
many people here did stuff like that
wash cars lemonade stands pack [ __ ] at
school and so you know like that's how
they're wired like me like that's all
you knew like my brain never thought
like oh let's go play Nintendo my brain
was like yo let's go buy a Nintendo and
sell it I'm gonna rent cartridges like
that's just all I've ever knew I don't
have another gear I'm [ __ ] basic I'm
one dimensional I saw nothing that's
awesome within this why you're so
celebrated right but there's a lot of
people here who aren't wired that way
and I don't think well they're lucky
this sucks but but we don't want to
discourage them there's some I'm not
discouraging them I just said they're
lucky like I wish
do you know how much do you know how
much I wish I wasn't so insane like do
you know how much more fun it would be
like I would be thrilled to leave twenty
percent of the money in the action and
the selfies on the table for a couple
more vacations to watch it be fun to
know what the [ __ ] on Netflix you know
like like I wish I'm not by the way I'm
not joking I'm gonna tell people to be
like me this isn't great this is just
who I am
let's talk about that self-awareness
right because that's the key to this you
are authentically you yeah I think the
Jews we're not saying be like Gary no
I'm saying how do I be you yeah and how
do people find that how do people find
that thing that's authentic I don't know
I really don't either they know when
it's not the results there are some
people who will be authentically
themselves in a shitty business and it
won't work great they may have
everything else going for them and you
tell those guys what triangle talk get
it no I mean what do you mean like
everything's going great for you but you
can't build a business great get an
awesome job that you like and your life
is [ __ ] set how many times should
beat me oh this year today is a result
of 15 years of hustle with one good
business and a dozen failures I kept at
it and I think we got something pretty
special here yep a lot of people don't
keep at it right how when do you know
when to throw in the towel you know I
think that's a personal question for
everybody right there's family dynamics
you may have a parent pass away it might
be a good thing like you're you're you
you've hit a zone where you're content
and this is what you want I don't think
to me that I you can see my tone has
changed I think is a very personal
question you know it's hard to judge I'm
sure there's plenty of people who gave
up one month before after doing it for
three years and that next month was
gonna be the moment and that's sad but I
think we all know there's so many people
that have gone too far and too long and
that hurt them I think that comes down
to self-awareness and looking at results
here's what I would say guys it doesn't
matter what I just said for the last 20
minutes it doesn't matter the reverse of
my argument for the last 20 minutes it's
a constant storm to try to figure out
what you're about and you change at 26
you're all about the hustle you're gonna
be a billionaire or this and that and
then you go to the bar one night and you
fall in love and it changes what you
about right and then you have a child
and then this happens and then that
happens things change
you just have to always consistently try
to figure out what's driving you and not
because other people are watching and
not because that's what your dad wants
and not that because that's what you
said was gonna happen and it doesn't
look like it and your family's gonna
judge you you just have to be as real
with yourself as possible and that is a
very difficult struggle but when you're
not you create enormous vulnerability
and unhappiness and that could be very
that could be very problematic
personally on your home life right I
mean how do you balance that over
communication you know Lizzie and I
talked and I never give people
relationship advice and people ask me
all the time because a lot of you know
that I work so much and everybody has
different relationships and I have to
over communicate with my wife and
understand how she's ticking and what's
making her happy and what's not and it's
and what she said last week is
irrelevant to tomorrow you know people
like oh you said you were gonna support
me that was two years ago and things
change and so it's a constant stream of
communication no different than what you
should be having with your employees and
your partners and you do that with your
spouse and and your partner and things
of that nature what's the average time
you get home at the end of each day 11
p.m. and you're offline weekends yes
does that work yes so far but it might
change and the kids are getting older
and it's not working for me one of the
biggest things that I want to change
going forward is coming home around
dinner and eat with them and then go
back out and so that's something for me
that's that you know like it evolves it
evolves I'm taking seven weeks vacation
now instead of two that's a lot that's a
big change for me that it evolves so
between weekends and seven weeks
vacation it's not like you know like I
don't know that seems like I feel lazy
yeah man
you got to pick up your game I'll try
how do you how do you so you mentioned
you know you don't have time for Netflix
you're on time for this other stuff but
how do you balance it but I have time
for the Jets for seven hours we know
that 16 times a year on a Sunday
everybody needs escapism you have to
understand and it's a great opportunity
with a lot of people watching for me to
clarify this I'm not judging you if
you're watching house of cards and play
Madden all day I'm judging you if you're
complaining that you're not successful
professionally and
doing that all day got it that's the
distinction do you you you know many
people are very happy making forty-five
thousand a year and surfing every
weekend making two hundred thousand a
year and it like I'm not sure who the
[ __ ] am I to judge you I'm judging the
people that email me every day saying my
shit's not working I'm not lucky I don't
get it and then are watching full
seasons of house of cards playing Madden
all day taking the entire weekend off I
didn't take any of my weekends off for
the first 15 years of my career so you
know I'm I'm just so you know all the
venom is for the complainers you're good
you won
how do you stay though with the curve
right like how do you how much time so
number one right I think this is one of
the best pieces of Isis most practical
you give check in the top 100 apps in
the App Store every single day you still
do that every day you do it today yep
see anything interesting nope only see
something interesting once or twice a
year that's the point and what's your
first move when that happens you reach
out to the back yeah yeah Phil Toronto
on my team go dig into this get me all
the information set up a drinks with a
founder find out if anybody invested set
up with them on it all in all [ __ ]
ships in audit audit made any of your
investments yet no but one is brewing
what do you what do you think of that
where is it going
I think people gonna lose a shitload of
money betting on VR consumer over the
next five years and I think that there's
a lot of opportunity in b2b and I think
15 years from now VR is gonna be a beast
we've got the CMO with the devil's here
today great who's gonna put headsets on
Devils mask so people can at home buy
tickets in watch via VR what do you
think I don't think it's gonna happen I
hope he's not here yet
he won by doing it cuz he wants to press
around doing it and that gives awareness
to the brand and that's a good KPI but
do I think everybody here is gonna watch
the devil's game next year on VR I do
not what do you think they'll do I say
everybody this is an early user crowd
right your app propeller I don't even I
don't think a good percentage of you
will do it I definitely don't think a
good percentage of Ricky Thompson who
knows nothing about tech is gonna do it
and that's what I care I care when Ricky
Thompson knows about snapchat I care
what Sally Arkansas cares about snapchat
not when
or [ __ ] McGee's on it I think he's
here where nerd worried huh what what do
you say what do you think is the number
one use case and I'll bring this up
because I think dude it's gonna take by
the way VR is the only potential
arbitrage to the Internet
it's the next platform it just might be
15 20 what's a good effect life shopping
entertainment gaming Oh dating you know
what you're leaving out though the
number one thing that tends to push tech
advancement is porn and that's where VR
is being pushed around I can't [ __ ]
wait for VR porn would you invest in
that uh maybe just to get the free
headset no I you know like I just think
could Sumer even pee even porn I think
is further away than people like look
consumer behavior is underestimated guys
only 20% of products are bought in
e-commerce like we're still buying in
stores in 1996 when I started
winelibrary.com 1997 if you told me that
in 2016 only 20% would be e-comm I would
have made fun of you you don't see the
future you don't get it it takes time
for behavior to change for you to sit at
home and live your lives through that
world or spend a meaningful amount of
time will take time I actually believe
it will happen but I think it's gonna be
a hell I think headsets will never be at
scale ever meaning by the time it's that
scale will be on contacts or some other
version I don't think we'll ever have
mass headsets at home doing VR mass mass
like everybody maybe but I just I'm I
don't see it I think it's gonna take too
long and they'll be advancements on the
headsets I gotta go right yeah we could
hold on one second okay the ethos of the
New Jersey Technica Meetup and they eat
those of this event is about helping
each other out great what can we do what
can people here do today to help you out
nothing that's not true you can't leave
here do you think of something zero I'm
super uncomfortable with the ask I don't
want anything from you right now and
that makes me happier than coming up
with themselves that you believe in
wholeheartedly that will make you feel
good do something nice for somebody else
that brings them
you without having expectations with
something in return which is something
most of you can't do ladies and
gentlemen Gary Vaynerchuk thank you guys
hold on buddy thank you guys look up
your club smile hands up